bonjour de retour en france un côté sue
très très très heureux je lis quand une
petite annonce et que farinër regardez
bien jean luc reichmann percuté par un
avion regarder parce que c'est vrai
c'est pas vous le voyez allant mois au
pain vous le voyez je les place dans
l'es2 alors je clique regardez bien je
clique dessus je clique la prime je
clique est là après jean-luc reichmann
percuté par un avion jeudi jean luc
reichmann percuté par un camion
je suis là
vous aviez départ j'ai été percuté par
la ville mais pas par le reste je vais
très très bien je moi je le redis
j'ai un jour il faut que tu attrapes la
pièce à 20,46
c'est bon
bravo hein autrefois petit dernier prix
ok
golaz répète après nous
[Musique]
banimmo
j'avoue depuis l'album de mantel adèle
j'ai pris quelques cours de chant et
j'assure maintenant mito va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]